y
aguanto y for smart zone sabe usted es
excelente pregunta a lebron y pues yo no
soy sal pero voy a contestar a su nombre
espero que ninguno de los dos se moleste
por ello y bueno antes de comenzar a
responder les muestro esta información
que busco ahora sin sal y que es del 18
octubre del 2009 es información del new
york times' quizás ya esté algo viejita
pero es muy interesante porque lo que
muestra esta gráfica es el número de
intentos que intentaron hacer los
equipos en promedio por temporada al
encestar una canasta de tres puntos
comparado contra la temporada y aquí
ustedes pueden ver que el tiro de tres
puntos se introdujo en el 79 y en
general siempre ha habido una tendencia
a intentar más y más tiros de 3 puntos
excepto aquí pueden ver algunas
anomalías aquí esta gráfica tiene un
salto eso se debe a que en estas
temporadas la línea
tres puntos se acercó más a la canasta
por lo tanto la gente latina va más y
por acá está digamos esta parte más baja
se debe a que en el 99 la temporada fue
más corta esta de aquí es así no tengo
ni idea que le explicamos pero bueno
lebron no nos preguntó acerca de el
promedio de tiros por equipo nos
preguntó acerca de el suyo así que aquí
tengo las estadísticas que tomamos de
nba.com y vamos a utilizar sus
estadísticas de carrera vamos a comparar
todos los tiros a lo largo de la
historia y bien nos preguntaba cuál es
la probabilidad o qué es más grande la
probabilidad de encestar una canasta de
tres puntos o encestar tres tiros libres
consecutivamente así que bien el
porcentaje que tiene el ebro dónde se
estará una canasta de tres puntos a lo
largo de su carrera
es de 0.33 uno que es decir si lo
convierte un porcentaje el porcentaje
que tiene de estar una canasta de tres
puntos es de aproximadamente el 33% y
que hay de los tiros libres pues los
tiros libres y están su porcentaje de
tiros libres es de 0.74 6 porcentaje de
tiros libres
no voy a redondear al 75% por lo tanto
tiene muchísima más probabilidad de
estar un tiro libre que uno de tres
puntos pero nosotros queremos saber qué
pasa con tres tiros libres consecutivos
y vamos a empezar pensando en el primer
tiro libre vamos a ponerle tiro libre
número uno
y qué sucede en este tiro libre pues
imagínense que tuviera una cantidad
absurdamente grande de lebron james
vamos a decir que fuera así como mil
millones o mil trillones de ellos copias
exactas y que todos están tirando un
tiro libre entonces lo que yo esperaría
ver es que el 75 por ciento de esta
cantidad absurda de lebron james es el
75 por ciento enceste ese tiro libre y
lógicamente es el 75 por ciento acción
encestó el 25 por ciento restante lo
falló así que más o menos esta es la
situación que tengo qué pasa con el tiro
libre número 2 tiro libre número 2
número 2 pues
que voy a observar realmente sólo me
interesa los lebron james que siguen
sentaron el tiro anterior el tiro libre
número uno así que esperaría que de
estos 75 % sólo el 75 por ciento en se
estarán el siguiente tiro libre así que
sé que está la mitad por aquí está el
75% más o menos más o menos una cantidad
así del total y todo lo demás todo lo
demás serían combinaciones de que
encestaron el primero pero no el segundo
que encestaron el el segundo pero no el
primero o que no es estar o ninguno de
los dos así que esta parte verde este
cachito es el 75%
del 75% lo que es lo mismo el 75 por
ciento por el 75 por ciento y finalmente
tengo el tiro libre número 3
y de nuevo solo me interesan los que han
estado los dos anteriores que voy a
suponer que sería
de este caso voy a tomar de nuevo el 75%
y obtendría algo así esto serían los 15
están los tres y es el 75% del 75%
tenía que arriba del 75%
así que el 75 por ciento por 75 por
ciento por 75 por ciento o lo que es lo
mismo la probabilidad de que esté los
tres tipos libros es de el 75 por ciento
al cubo
el cubo pero esto es lo mismo que 75
cada 100
al cubo que es lo mismo que 0.75
al cubo y cuánto es eso cuánto es ese
número bien entonces tengo 0.75 por 0.75
por 0.75 este pequeño asterisco de aquí
es multiplicación y me da 0.42 18 hacia
aproximadamente el 42% y noten que sería
lo mismo si pongo 0.75 elevado al cubo
nos da el mismo resultado pero bueno
entonces esto es aproximadamente
aproximadamente el 0.42 que es igual al
42%
por lo tanto lebron tiene una
posibilidad mayor de estar tres tiros
libres consecutivamente es que debes
estar un tiro de tres puntos el tiro
tres puntos sólo tiene la probabilidad
del 33 por ciento y bueno les encargó
pensar qué pasaría si estos dos números
hubieran sido distintos como habría
afectado eso el resultado final y los
retos encontrar un jugador de la nba que
tenga mayor posibilidad
estar un tiro de tres puntos quédense
estar tres tiros libres consecutivamente